>> Tucker: IT HAS BEEN MANY
MONTHS SINCE THE MASS SHOOTING
IN LAS VEGAS, THE LARGEST IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
EVEN NOW KEY INFORMATION
CONTINUES TO TRICKLE OUT.
EVEN AS STEPHEN PADDOCK
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION IS, WHY IS
THIS FOOTAGE COMING OUT NOW AND
WHY DID THE POLICE NOT ACT FOR
SEVERAL MINUTES?
CATHERINE BARDO IS AN ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE VICTIMS
OF THOSE SHOOTINGS AND SHE JOINS
US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS, WHY ARE
WE FINDING THIS OUT NOW?
IT SEEMS LIKE A CENTRAL PIECE OF
INFORMATION IN THE STORY.
>> BECAUSE THE COURTS ORDERED
THE LAS VEGAS METRO POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO RELEASE ALL OF
THIS VIDEO FOOTAGE AND PURSUANT
TO COURT ORDER, THEY ARE
RELEASING IT PIECE BY PIECE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS.
AS YOU KNOW, YESTERDAY WE
RECEIVED ABOUT A DOZEN VIDEOS
AND MANY MORE AUDIO VIDEOS
SHOWING MOSTLY POLICE OFFICER
BODY WORN CAMERA FOOTAGE.
IT'S FASCINATING AND IT IS ALSO
VERY, VERY UPSETTING.
IT SHOWS THE EXTREMIS OF THE
EVENT AND OF THE TRAUMA THAT
EVERYONE THERE, THE 22,000
PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE HAVE
SUFFERED.
I HAVE BEEN IN THAT VERY HALLWAY
32ND FLOOR.
AND WHAT THE VIDEO CLEARLY SHOWS
IS ONE PARTICULAR POLICE OFFICER
WAS ON THE 31ST FLOOR.
NOT THE 32ND FLOOR, AND HE WAS
THERE FOR MANY MOMENTS.
WHAT WE FIND INTERESTING IS THAT
THE MANDALAY BAY SECURITY
OFFICER WHO WAS WITH THAT
PARTICULAR POLICE OFFICER BEFORE
THE SHOOTING STARTED AND RACED
THROUGH THE CASINO FLOOR AND
RACED UP THE ELEVATORS WITH HIM,
THIS PARTICULAR MANDALAY BAY
SECURITY GUARD SAID THAT HE WAS
ON THE 30 SECOND-FLOOR WITH THAT
PARTICULAR OFFICER IN THE VIDEO
ON THE 31ST FLOOR.
THIS MANDALAY BAY SECURITY
MANAGER TOLD THE FBI ON NINE
SEPARATE OCCASIONS IN HIS
INTERVIEWS THAT HE WAS CERTAIN
HE WAS WITH THIS OFFICER HENDRIX
ON THE 30 SECOND-FLOOR.
THEY ALREADY KNEW OFFICER
HENDRIX WAS ON THE 31ST FLOOR
BUT, IT WASN'T UNTIL YESTERDAY
WHEN ALL OF THAT VIDEO WAS
RELEASED THAT WE FINALLY GOT
CONFIRMATION THAT SOMETHING IS
WRONG, SOMETHING IS AMISS.
SCRATCHED THE SURFACE.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME IN
SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE SEEN ARMED
POLICE OFFICERS STAND THERE
WHILE A MASS MURDER TAKES PLACE.
I'M SYMPATHETIC TO COPS BECAUSE
THEY TAKE A LOT OF BUT I THINK
WE DESERVE AN EXPLANATION FOR
WHY THIS KEEPS HAPPENING.
>> AS ON MY.
ONE LAST THOUGHT ON THAT, I HAVE
A CLIENT WHOSE SPOUSE WAS SHOT
AND I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT